- Hi, everyone, Sal here.
Welcome to the, I guess,
"Homeroom With Sal" livestream.
The name keeps evolving a little bit.
A couple of quick announcements.
First of all, we, we were hoping
to have Lester Holt today,
but him being in the news industry,
there has been some news I
believe that has taken him away.
So unfortunately, we've
had to postpone that.
I was really looking
forward to that interview,
but I'm hoping we will have it
in the next couple of weeks.
The other standard
announcements I will make,
so instead of Lester Holt,
you're just gonna get me.
So we're gonna do an "Ask Me Anything."
So you can even start putting
the questions you might have
on YouTube and Facebook
below the livestream,
and we'll get to that to a few minutes,
and literally ask about anything.
The other announcements,
my standard announcement,
just a reminder that Khan Academy
is a not-for-profit organization,
that we exist because of
philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about making
a donation to Khan Academy.
I wanna make a special shout-out
to several organizations
that have stepped up
when they learned that we
were running at a deficit
even before the COVID crisis,
and that deficit only
grew as our server costs
and our need to support more
folks grew through the crisis.
Special thanks to Bank of America,
Google.org, AT&T, Fastly, Novartis,
and actually the Amgen Foundation as well.
And then my last announcement
is some enterprising
Khan Academy team members have realized
that a lot of what we do in the livestream
makes for a good podcast,
with a little bit of
editing here and there.
So if you are into listening to podcasts,
you wanna listen to some of
our interesting conversations
that we've had with some
really impressive people
from the car or wherever else,
please check out "Homeroom
With Sal, The Podcast,"
which you can find wherever
you typically find podcasts
in your life.
So with that, let's start this AMA.
So the first question,
there's already a couple of
questions that are coming in.
Actually, this was a
question we had from before,
but it's a good one.
Adarsh Persona from YouTube had asked,
"Hi, Sal, I heard that it is possible
to take an SAT in seventh grade.
Do you recommend this?"
My view is it depends on your motivation.
I think if you are a seventh grader
and you're just curious about it
and you wanna have kind of
a run at taking the SAT,
I think that's fine, that's great.
And there's a lot of good
things that can come of that.
If you take it, it'll build
your comfort with the test.
You'll essentially be
entering into high school
with a little bit more information,
a little bit more context,
so that's a good thing.
There's also a lot of
programs that you can get into
if you do reasonably well on the SAT
as a middle schooler,
which are pretty neat.
There's the Duke Talent Search, I believe.
I think Johns Hopkins has a program.
I believe Stanford has a program.
So there's a bunch of programs like that.
So if you're someone who likes to be
on the precocious side of things,
I don't think there's harm in taking it.
Now, the only reason I wouldn't take it
is if you feel some type of
pressure or stress around it,
if you're like, "Oh, I've gotta take it
'cause everyone else is taking
it, but it stresses me out,"
then I wouldn't do it.
But generally speaking, I do
advocate it in middle school.
It's not a bad idea to take it.
It just makes you familiar with something.
You learn a little bit about stuff,
you learn what you know,
what you don't know,
and it's completely okay to take a test
that you haven't learned
some of the material.
The SAT, for example, in
math goes up to Algebra II
and really just the core of Algebra II,
and so most seventh
graders would not have seen
that material yet, but it's
interesting to see it on a test
and then see it later in your classroom.
I would also say that if
you're going to take the SAT,
try to brush up a little bit
or learn a little bit of algebra.
You'd be surprised how far it'll get you.
But I don't think it's a bad idea.
I think it could be interesting
as long as you have a good
mindset going into it.
So from YouTube, Georgie Grogan asked,
"Do you think Khan Academy works better
for younger or older people?"
It depends, we have stuff on Khan Academy
for almost every age group.
We have Khan Academy Kids
and we have some really
cool efficacy studies there.
If you have a three-year-old,
four-year-old,
five-year-old, six-year-old,
I highly recommend Khan Academy Kids.
If we're talking about
say learning Algebra I
on Khan Academy, I think
we do see a lot of adults
that when they went
through it the first time
in eighth or ninth grade,
and they might not have
perceived themselves
as strong math students,
when they do it as adults,
they have a little bit more maturity,
they're a little bit more driven.
They're internally motivated.
They're often very, very
successful at learning things
that they didn't learn
the first time in school.
I think if you're a student,
it's really the degree to
which you can motivate yourself
to really do the work.
And we see a lot of students
who are very capable of doing that.
In a lot of ways, that skill, that ability
to kind of drive your own learning
is maybe even more important
than the math itself.
So I wouldn't say it necessarily
works better or worse
for older or younger people,
but I think everyone needs
different degrees of support.
For folks who are very
motivated and very driven,
regardless of their age and
regardless of their capability,
their starting capability, I
think it can work very well.
And then I think other folks
need different degrees of supports
and it might be supports
from their teachers,
supports from peers.
Obviously, all of us at Khan Academy
are constantly thinking of new mechanics,
new ways of showing the information,
so to make it as engaging as possible.
It's not obvious that older
or younger is a benefit.
From YouTube, AZ asks,
"What are you planning
to do after quarantine?"
After quarantine, so I've
said this a couple of times
in the livestreams, obviously
what we're going through
as a world is a horrible
and bizarre situation,
but there are certain aspects of it
that I'm actually starting to get used to
and in certain ways enjoy.
The fact that my kids are at
home, I'm working from home,
my wife is working from home
two or three days a week now,
at first, it was hard
'cause sometimes I'm recording a video
and all of a sudden my
five-year-old's screaming
20 feet away, it can kind of
mess up your concentration.
But one, I've kinda gotten
used to that a little bit
and now I've started to enjoy
hearing my five-year-old scream
or when I get a break or get lunch,
I get to see them or spend a
little bit of time with them
or take a break with them
or take a walk with them.
I'm realizing that time
goes by very, very fast.
If you are a kid, your
childhood would go by fast,
and if you're a parent,
your kid's childhood is
gonna go by very fast.
And I think to be able to spend
this extra time with family,
even if it's incidental,
we see each other while we're eating lunch
and things like that,
I think that's going to be something
that I want to retain as
much as I can post-COVID.
I think something about
COVID has made us connect
with a lot of friends and family
that we otherwise, frankly,
wouldn't have connected with,
at least as regularly on
Zoom or whatever else.
I hope that's something
that I keep post-COVID.
I've always been the person
who likes spending a lotta time outdoors.
I live out here in Northern California
where the weather is quite nice.
Pre-COVID I used to go
to gatherings and say,
"Why aren't we outside?
And people say, "It's 60
degrees, it's so cold."
And I'm like, "No, but
it's outside, it's nature."
I actually like the fact in COVID
that we're forced to go
outside, and if we do socialize,
socially distance in
a park, in a backyard,
the stuff I that wanna get.
Yeah, so those are my big ones.
Obviously, the things
that I miss right now
are my mom lives in New
Orleans, she's by herself.
I would love her to be
able to come and visit us
or us to visit her,
but obviously, she's in a high risk group
and it would be hard to travel
on a plane right now because of that.
I think that's the stuff that I can't wait
we get through that part,
'cause I think that it's taking a big tax
on families who are apart right now.
And I know I'm very lucky
considering all else
that's going in the world.
A lot of people are really having,
above and beyond the COVID
hardship or the COVID fear
and the quarantine hardship,
are having economic hardships.
That's gonna be huge when
we get back to normalcy,
people are gonna be able to, you know,
restaurants will reopen,
et cetera, et cetera.
So from Facebook, Tracy Harris is saying,
"I have some students
who are still struggling
with mastering their
multiplication and division facts.
How can I help them?"
Great question, Tracy.
And I would say we do not talk enough
about the importance of
things like math facts.
And I think sometimes,
let's call it the education establishment,
we don't talk about it as much
because it feels so simple
or it's not as sophisticated
as talking about the deeper standards
of integrating knowledge
and going higher up Bloom's taxonomy.
But I can't tell you how
many young people I've seen,
I've visited sixth-grade classrooms
where it's pretty clear that
a majority of the students
really didn't have fluency in
some of their core math facts
around addition or multiplication.
And because of that, it
was just holding them back,
and even if they knew how to
kind of think about the problem
and construct equations,
when they hit 9 times 6,
they would just write 56 instead of 54
and get the whole thing wrong.
And so it's super important.
I think, to some degree, that
COVID is a really good time
for everyone to make sure
that they have really strong foundations,
including some middle school.
I've met high school students
who really don't have fluency
in their multiplication facts.
What I would highly recommend
doing is making it social.
It's kind of very old-school.
Sit down with the flashcards.
I think you can order them on online,
get some multiplication flashcards,
and sit down with your child
and go through them and say,
"We're gonna do this 10 minutes a day."
You know what I've been
doing with my nine-year-old,
she essentially knows her multiplication,
but it's not fluent yet, in
the morning at breakfast,
I'll go, "6 times 8 real fast."
And I'll just do two
or three every morning
just to see if she can get her fluency.
She gets a little annoyed.
She rolls her eyes, but
then she'll go, "48,"
and the 48 is coming out a little faster.
Anyone who's spent a lot
of time on Khan Academy
would know I'm not an advocate
generally of memorization
or rote memorization of things.
It's very important to have an intuition
and to really understand what's going on,
but multiplication facts,
obviously the students should understand
what multiplication is and
how you can even derive
if you know that 6 times 8 is 48,
if you wanna know 6 times 9,
well, you just add
another 6, you get to 54.
But at some point in your life,
it has to come very, very automatic.
Otherwise, you're gonna be
spending too much cognitive load
on the multiplication versus
the higher order things
that you're trying to do.
So let's see, there's YouTube,
AZ, another question from AZ,
who asks a lotta questions
about quarantine,
but these are good questions.
"What's one thing you've
learnt during quarantine?"
Well, it depends on what you mean learn.
If it's kind of like learning about life,
I talked a lot about it,
is that it's nice to spend
more time with the family,
nice to connect with
past friends and family
over videoconference.
I'm finding that, obviously,
the workplace has had to go,
everyone's workplace where
possible has had to go remote,
especially people who've
had traditionally desk jobs,
so to speak.
It's seeming for certain folks,
it's becoming a lot harder.
And for other folks they're
actually enjoying it
because it's less of a commute,
they're actually feeling more productive.
So it's been interesting that
a lot of our societal norms,
which probably wouldn't have
been questioned deeply before,
but quarantine has
forced us to question it,
I think I've learned that the
standard assumptions about it
are maybe not a hundred percent true.
If you're talking about knowledge
that I've gained during quarantine,
let's see, what am I, what am I,
off the cuff, I don't
have any new factoids.
I've learned some things in
this livestream situation.
I'll keep thinking about that question.
So from Facebook, Misty Schwaller asks,
"What are you currently reading?"
So I think I've answered this before,
and it will tell you
how long this book is,
the fact that it's been several weeks
that I'm going to give
you the same answer.
I'm reading "Shantaram"
by I think his name is Gregory
David Roberts is the author.
Now for young people,
I definitely do not recommend reading it.
It's about someone who escaped
from prison in Australia
and then kind of joins the Bombay mafia,
and in some ways it kind of celebrates
the vibrancy of life in India in the '80s.
But there's a lotta darkness to it,
a lotta violence to it.
I'm normally not a fan of violence,
but a friend recommended that I read it.
There's some interesting
philosophical aspects of the book,
but it's a long book,
and it gets a little darker
than I normally like,
but that is what I have been reading.
I'm almost done.
I'm eager to think about
what I will read next though.
I'm open to any recommendations.
From Facebook, Hussein Rumi,
"Can you recommend some
books from your shelf?"
Yes, and some people have
wondered, is that a real shelf,
with this world of zoom backgrounds,
but this is very much a real shelf,
and this shelf has some of
my favorite books on it.
There's a bunch of science
fiction books here.
We have "Ender's Game," which is,
if anyone hasn't read
"Ender's Game," I envy you,
because you get to read it now.
And I think this is appropriate
for anyone maybe in
middle school and above.
But even if you're 50
and if you haven't read "Ender's Game,"
you will love "Ender's Game."
And the book as normally is the case
is much better than the movie.
And I have the other books in the Ender's.
Actually, I have two copies
of "Ender's Game" here.
I'd let you borrow one if we
weren't so socially distanced,
but then I have the
other books in the series
where Ender travels through
space and comes in contact.
But I just have a ton, I have
the Foundation series here.
So that's my science fiction.
There's a ton that you're not seeing.
I have, what do I have?
This "Name of the Wind," Patrick Rothfuss,
that's more fantasy, but
highly, highly recommend it.
"Lifespan," David Sinclair,
we had him on as a guest
a couple of weeks ago.
Then we have, you probably
can't see all of books here,
"The Gene" by Siddhartha Mukherjee.
Yeah, but that's just some of it.
I don't want to bore you all.
"Forever War," Joe Haldeman,
all interesting books.
Let's see, from YouTube, SpiritLifter,
I like your username.
"What is the best way to
do independent work at home
if your parents aren't home?"
Sometimes your parents could
be a distraction. (chuckling)
But sometimes, obviously,
parents can help you stay focused
and provide the environment.
So, SpiritLifter, I don't
know how old you are
or what type of independent work
you are trying to accomplish at home,
but my advice is, is try to build a habit.
I've talked to this researcher
who talks about the Pomodoro Technique,
and it's named after this timer
that's shaped like a
tomato, a Pomodoro tomato.
And it's this notion of set a regular time
where you're gonna be able
to focus on your goals,
try to do it in 20 minute spurts.
Say, okay, the next 20
minutes, I'm gonna work,
and then after the 20 minutes,
you set a timer or put it
on your phone or something,
on the computer, and then
give yourself a break.
Let yourself do something you enjoy,
and then do another 20 minutes.
And that's a really good
way of not procrastinating.
And then when you are
doing those 20 minutes,
and hopefully it's at the same time,
you have good lighting,
you have good posture,
you're not slouched on
the bed or on the couch.
You're doing it at a desk or at a table
that you just try.
Well, I would say just the
habit of staying engaged.
Even if at first, it might
be a little bit difficult,
slowly that habit will build,
and you will be able to
make progress on your work.
I think it doesn't hurt to set goals
per day, per week, per month.
Having a checklist for
the day is a great way
to have a bit of a dopamine hit
every time you accomplish something
and it kind of builds momentum.
I've talked about this
in previous livestreams.
I like to start my day
with some easy wins.
I always make my bed, 'cause I'm like,
there, I've already done
something, I've made my bed,
and it's something I'm gonna
benefit from in about 16 hours.
I'm pretty ritualistic
about my morning run,
doing some meditation, doing some pushups,
brushing my teeth, making the
bed, et cetera, et cetera.
The more that you can build these habits
and these patterns and get some wins
and check some stuff off of your checklist
early on, the better.
So let's see, other questions.
So Musaki Yamamoto asked,
"Hey, Sal, would you
send your kids to school
if you lived in a high-case state?"
Interesting question.
My kids' school is actually
we live I think in a...
California is having high cases.
When you look at it per
capita, it's reasonably high.
Our county is not like
off the charts high,
but it's having cases.
The city I live in, in Mountain View,
actually has relatively low incidents.
I think they've only had
a hundred or so cases
in a population of I believe 75,000,
if I have my numbers right.
I might be wrong.
So the way I think about it is,
the evidence we're seeing is
that the youngest kids are...
There's not a lot of
evidence that we're seeing
that they are the spreaders.
They usually are the spreaders
for things like the cold and the flu,
but most of the data that I've seen
is that they aren't
the spreaders of COVID.
And those are also the kids
that probably benefit the most
from in-person social interaction.
I'm lucky, as I mentioned, I
live in Northern California.
The weather's very good.
Most days in the summer,
the weather's in the 70s
and in the low 80s, and in
the winter, it's in the 60s.
And so I think for the younger kids,
some type of outdoor schooling
that still takes all the precautions
could be very interesting.
And I know the school my kids go to,
they are looking at that
for the youngest kids,
for the kindergartners,
first, and second graders.
And they're trying to get
a variance from the state
that would allow them to serve that.
This is just my family,
everyone has to make the right choices,
I would be open to that as a parent.
But I think as you get to older students,
given where we are at COVID right now,
especially if you're not
outdoors, if you're indoors,
I'd be very concerned about that.
And I wouldn't feel
comfortable sending my kids
to something that's spending
a lot of time indoors
given where COVID is.
But the more time outdoors,
socially-distanced, masks on,
feels like it could work
in a lotta circumstances.
But yeah, it's current thinking.
We're all struggling with
the same questions right now.
But one thing that I think is interesting
is even with social
distancing, as I mentioned,
especially those young kids,
frankly, everyone needs
social interactions,
if you have local parks,
if you have a backyard,
meeting with a small group of folks,
just one other family, socially
distanced with masks on,
I think is a good way to get
some of that social interaction
that I think, frankly, we all need,
but kids probably need it especially.
So from Facebook, Julius,
apologies if I'm not
pronouncing this correctly,
Surenokis, "Are college-level
math courses in the plans?"
Well, Julius, we do have some
college-level math courses,
depending on what you
consider college-level.
We obviously have statistics, calculus,
we actually have multivariable calculus.
We're actually gonna be launching
exercises for that soon.
And we also have videos
in differential equations,
linear algebra,
so it kinda gets into your
freshmen/sophomore level,
college-level classes.
I do hope eventually,
our focus is really
doing the K through 12,
and then a little bit
of that early college,
I do hope eventually Khan Academy
is able to add some of the
more advanced math classes.
In my mind, that's when math
really gets interesting,
and I missed some of those courses,
and I would love nothing
more than to re-dive deep
into those courses and cover
some of that with you all.
So from Facebook, Shannon
Seabeck asks or says,
"Google has started
offering free certificates
for career paths in
things like data analytics
or project management.
Do you think this will
eventually be commonplace
and a real alternative to a
costly college education?"
Simple answer is yes.
I don't think it's gonna be an either/or,
I think people are gonna try
to do combinations of both,
but I think you're gonna
see a lot of people
with college degrees try to
get some of these certificates.
And if employers like
Google or the Microsofts
or the Facebooks of the world said,
"Yeah, we'll hire you
if you are able to
achieve this certificate,"
then, yeah, that will
have a lot of cachet,
maybe even more than a college degree.
And I think that'll be
healthy if there's more paths,
more variety of ways to
essentially build your skills
and have economic opportunity.
College will always be a path
and a lot of great things about college,
but for certain people,
the costs, the time,
the things that it focuses on
might not be exactly right.
So I'm always a big fan a larger diversity
of opportunity and paths.
So from YouTube, AiyanaAisheForever says,
"Mr. Sal, I'm really
suffering with the SAT,
the English section.
Do you have any tips for it?"
Well, it depends how much
time you have for it.
I mean, the English section of the SAT,
it really is if you read a lot
and your language usage is solid
in terms of kind of
grammar language usage,
you should do okay.
I think one thing that hurts
a lot of people is maybe reading speed,
and there, I would say, just
practice, practice, practice.
Practice will only benefit you.
We see that in the data, on
the official SAT practice
that we do in partnership
with the College Board,
that the more people practice,
the more that they do
the recommended activity,
the more that they take practice tests,
the more that they really
focus on practicing skills
at kinda their learning edge,
those students are growing the most.
So that's what I would recommend.
To earlier questions
about how do you do that?
Build a habit.
Say every day I'm gonna do,
if the verbal or the English section
is what's giving you trouble,
every day I'm gonna do an hour.
By hook or by crook, everyday
I'm gonna do an hour.
And I think after several weeks of that,
you're definitely gonna
notice improvement.
Your reading speed is going to improve.
You're going to just feel more comfortable
and less stressed in the test as well.
So there's from Facebook,
Sandra Sand says does Khan...
Oh, I only have five minutes left.
Time goes by fast.
"Does Khan Academy have
a larger strategy or plan
to support remote learning
during the pandemic?"
The simple answer, Sandra,
is yes, we are trying.
We're doing the work
we've always been doing
with teachers and districts
and parents and families.
We've been also been doing
these learning plans.
We've been running webinars
for parents and teachers
on how to do distance learning.
Expect an op-ed from me
in a major newspaper soon
about what good distance
learning could look like.
We are actually publishing a
study on distance learning,
not just using Khan Academy,
but also using live videoconferences.
What is the best practice there?
We've obviously just published
our get ready for grade level courses
to allow students and teachers
to make sure students have
all the prerequisites filled,
so they're ready for grade level,
any gaps that they might
have accrued over COVID
or even before that.
I've talked about the
project Schoolhouse.world.
This is a project, it's not
officially part of Khan Academy.
It's a separate volunteer-driven
project right now.
Maybe one day it'll become
part of Khan Academy.
But it was catalyzed by
this COVID situation,
where you have Khan Academy,
it's a place where kids
and families can go
to get their practice, to get supports,
they have hints, they have solutions,
they have videos, they have articles.
But what about live sessions
with a real teacher,
a real tutor?
And that's what the goal
at Schoolhouse.world is.
It's a place where students can go
and pick which areas they need help in,
and they can get free live
group tutoring sessions
with vetted tutors who are volunteers.
So if anyone's interested in that,
I highly recommend going
to Schoolhouse.world.
But this is kind of the portfolio of stuff
that we're trying to do in preparation
for what's going to
clearly be a very strange
back-to-school season or year.
We wanna make sure that
Khan Academy is there
for as much practice and
learning as possible,
and we can help provide
some guidance and a view
of how that can fit into
a more holistic picture
for teachers and families.
So let's see, from Facebook, Julie Frisk,
"Are there best practices
for distance learning
for high school?
It seems that they
would be more successful
if they were taking fewer classes
rather than the typical nine periods."
So, Julie, I couldn't agree
more with your intuition.
I think, frankly, even in normal times,
nine periods is like that's a lotta breath
and a lotta stress.
That's not a good idea.
It's much better to do fewer courses
and be able to focus on them,
and especially in a time of COVID.
What I've been telling
people at all grade levels,
at all age levels, is
focus first and foremost
on the math, the reading, and the writing.
Make sure those don't atrophy.
If you can put in even 40,
if you're a high school student,
let's call it 45 minutes a day
of solid active work
practice in each of those,
math, and reading, and writing every day,
you're going to not atrophy
and you'll probably progress,
and the reading and the writing, for sure,
can be very low tech.
It could be go find a book list
of books appropriate for your grade level
or whatever reading level you're at,
read those books, find a group of people
that you can talk about them with.
Hopefully, your teacher is
leading you through this,
but even if you're not
getting that support,
find some students, some peers,
who wanna go on this journey with you,
or some families, if you're
a parent of a high schooler
that will do this with you.
The writing, every week, pick
something to write about,
and you could mix it up through the year.
I'm gonna write a couple of short stories.
I'm gonna write a couple
of opinion pieces.
I'm gonna write an analysis
of whether we should open schools,
or something like that,
and put them on a blog,
put them on Medium or something,
and send them to all
your friends and family
and get feedback from
them and ask for feedback.
How could this be better?
How can I improve this and iterate on it?
I think if you do that,
you're not going to atrophy
and you're actually going
to develop a lot of skills.
And then once you have your
legs under yourself there,
then I would layer on maybe one science
and one social science,
a history and whatever
science you're working on,
whether it's physics, chemistry, biology.
And if you do that, that's really solid,
especially while we go
through this pandemic,
and make sure that you
have enough time for sleep,
enough time for socializing,
enough time for exercise,
time with your family.
Because I think the biggest
risk we have right now
is just people burning out
and the mental health
issues that might happen
because of quarantine.
So, I agree with your intuition
to kind of focus on doing fewer things,
but doing them better and
not stressing ourselves out
or spreading ourselves too thin
in this very, very difficult time.
So, it looks like we're almost outta time.
Let's see if there's any
questions I could answer.
Let's see, from YouTube,
there's a lotta numbers in
this username, T0RicksCain3S,
"Do you have any suggestions
for remembering factual information
in subjects like history?"
I'm not the best memorizer in the world,
so take anything I have to
say with a grain of salt,
but what I find is the more ways
that you can represent
knowledge to yourself,
and the more connections you can draw,
the more that you will retain.
When you look at these people
who are like "Guinness Book
of World Record" memorizers,
what they'll tell is you they
have visualizations they do.
So if they're trying to
memorize a list of objects,
like a cat, a clock, spaghetti, and shoe,
the way that they will memorize that
is that they'll say, "Oh,
okay, I'm going to go,"
they'll visualize a story
that they walk into a room
and then the cat comes and it meows.
And just as it meows, you
notice that there's a clock
right behind the cat, and
so you enter the room,
you look at the clock, and you realize,
"Oh my god, it's time for spaghetti.
I can smell the spaghetti.
Let me enter it into the
kitchen and have the spaghetti."
And the analogy, the
good thing about history
is that history already
has a narrative with it.
(chuckling) You don't have to make one up
with some cat and the clock and spaghetti.
A history, there are connections.
And so what I would recommend you do
is don't just memorize that
World War I started in 1914,
and Kennedy was inaugurated in 1961,
just blindly memorize facts.
Think about what else was
going on in the world.
Think about, okay, in 1917,
what was the state of technology?
Visualize it, think about, wow,
that was two years before
the Spanish flu hit.
What was it like to live then?
What was going on in
other parts of the world
where maybe they weren't at
war, or other parts of the world
where your history books aren't covering,
and the more connections you draw,
the more that you'll have a frame.
And then those years and
those dates and those names
and those places will kind of
very naturally fit into place.
So, unfortunately, we're all out of time.
This always goes much faster.
I guess I like to answer questions.
But thanks so much for
joining the livestream today.
Once again, my apologies
for those of you all
hoping to see Lester Holt.
That obviously would have been
an improvement over just me,
but we are hoping to get him soon.
He had to delay because
of some breaking news.
But I look forward to
continuing this shortly.
So, thanks everyone for joining this AMA,
this "Ask Me Anything" livestream.
(computer chiming)